einer meiner größten träume ist es
irgendwann mal einen eigenen hund zu
haben ich liebe golden retrievers über
alles da ist davon allerdings kein spiel
gibt habe ich gedacht wir spielen heute
noch mit einer katze und das ist gilbert
das hier ist auf jeden fall gilbert er
stoppte gerade durch eine turnhalle rum
wenn wir die linke maustaste drücken
macht er ein leichtes mio
das jetzt gerade das tutorial wir müssen
hier erst mal die fische einsammeln
genau das heißt nicht auf hierzu mal
hintenrum hin dass auch noch offen
jetzt sammelt man das spiel
durchgespielt
wir können auch hüpfen indem wir die
rechte maustaste drücken da kann man
beispielsweise auch solche teile hier
drauf hüpfen und sind dann jetzt hier
drauf
helfer bis dahin ich weiß nicht wie ich
den fisch da oben kriegen soll das heißt
ich schaue jetzt mal was dass sie hinten
überhaupt findet ante s m hallo hallo
kann ich irgendwie mit der hier buch ach
ich kann auch auslaufen ich würde sagen
wir scheißen auf das tutorial hier und
geht man nach draußen im hallo freunde
gilbert in der großen weiten stadt hier
dahinter haben im basketball kann ich
den ball nicht irgendwie
ich bin der beste basketballspieler der
welt ist auf z samt auf der rechten hieß
es auf er ich habe noch viele andere
möglichkeiten also wenn ich er drücke
dann okay dann legt er wohl irgendwie
ein wenig z drücken
basics kann ich auch noch drücken
auf jeden fall ist das hier wohl die
stadt durch die wir laufen sollen das
sieht alles sehr schön aus hier die
ganzen häuser das heißt wir gehen jetzt
hier einfach mal raus und seen laden
dass dafür ein kaktus ein paar sekunden
später
warum bin ich jetzt wieder im menü sind
jetzt irgendwie wieder hier hinten
man muss jetzt hier wieder die fische
einsammeln ich weiß allerdings nicht da
der derzeitige hängigen der getit bei
kleinen wäldchen horse and presentation
john button ich weiß nicht genau was
dieses voting horses oder so aber
wahrscheinlich dass hier wo ich hier
raus springen muss also genau so springt
man darauf flog am brauneck bargen heute
so drauf was war das denn da unten
gerade ich weiß nicht was sie für ein
komischer mensch ist aber nicht zu der
in laufend wie so richtig behindert weg
alter ist bescheuert er guckt ihr euch
was ist das sie verteidigt sich gerade
von einer katze hält sich die komplette
steuer kann ich nicht mal mit der schon
die reihen laufen und dann
ich glaube ich muss sich irgendwie
rammeln das heißt ich gehe jetzt mal sie
rein und hier noch mal und jetzt kommen
jetzt bleibt einmal stehen ihr verdammte
scheiße was ist er mit ihr helfer system
mit ihr los ist sie komplett bescheuert
wieso kann ich dir nicht irgendwie
rahmen da steht die ganze zeit die soll
mit dem gesparten sie reinlaufen wie
läuft die ganze zeit nur so bescheiden
weg 2000 fische okay das habe ich jetzt
hingekriegt das heißt diese komische
tante hier wie sieht die eigentlich aus
sie trägt solider eine flip flops eine
schwarze hose handschuhe und ob also
keine ahnung was das jetzt soll ich kann
jetzt hier auf jeden fall langlaufen das
ist der exit ich will aber mal ein
bisschen durch die stadt stellte jetzt
mal hier auf jetzt gehe ich mal hier
drauf jetzt hatte ich mal hier hoch das
heißt theoretisch kann ich jetzt da
hinten rüber laufen mal schauen ob das
ganze funktioniert wie funktioniert
nämlich gar nicht jetzt trotz mal wieder
hier raus aber ich denke dadurch dass
ich alle fische habe und auch die
goldenen kann ich jetzt nicht mehr das
tutorial spielen sondern kann dies in
die normale welt
wieso steht hier immer noch nur tutorial
welcher mega cool einfach dass ich jetzt
alles noch mal machen muss es ja nicht
so dass nicht wohin schon alle fische
eingesammelt habe so ich habe wieder den
goldenen fisch jetzt am start
diese tante da vorne gammelt ein
bisschen hinter dem tor die ist
natürlich komplett normal
also sollte ich mal da befreien kommen
dass ich mal ganz kurz heraus dann
kannst du dich auch wieder normal
bewegen hier fort auch halo na bist du
denn kann ich dich irgendwie hey kannst
du auch teuer
oh mein gott wie so kann er sich aber um
kratzen ich verstehe das nicht ich kann
mich zwar auch hinsetzen aber warum kann
gewährt sich nicht am ohr kratzen hey
was ist denn falsch mit ihm kann ich
noch drücken aber sie dabei auch nichts
xy blatter passiert auch die ganze zeit
nichts und so jetzt bin ich wieder
normal hier also mehr da hinten macht
wohl auch nichts wenn sie hier vorne
hey wollen wir freunde seien also
irgendwie will sicherheiten freundin mit
mir sein das heißt ich kann ja mal
irgendwie wegschubsen hier oder so
kannst du jetzt mal vielleicht mal hier
da war ein ausrufezeichen bei ihrem kopf
kann ich nicht ich will einfach
eins von vier haben wir jetzt schon
vielleicht muss ich einfach so ein
bisschen ecken oder milch mit dem
bisschen beschäftigen hey hey jetzt hab
ich schon 254 vielleicht brauche ich
einfach ein paar freunde ich denke das
ist ganz so abläuft dass ich hier
irgendwie katzen finden muss und die
sind ja alle irgendwo versteckt oder so
aber mir wird das auch hier wieder nicht
gesagt das ist ja einfach wieder mal
total blöd ich weiß dass ich auch in die
normale welt gehen kann aber jetzt
irgendwie wollen und nicht jetzt wieder
eine unsichtbare band kann ich dann hier
reingucken irgendwie das häufig da ihr
oben noch irgendwie einen see oder so
also ich meine wir haben erst zwei von
vier das heißt es muss ja eigentlich
noch mehr geben hier vorne sie wieder
diese unsichtbare wand wo ich nicht lang
an gleicht einem mülleimer oder sony
hier ist auch keiner
ich würde sagen gilbert
kann ich das fahrrad benutzen ich was
will sie denn überhaupt ich will mit
euch eigentlich nur die normale welt und
jetzt bin ich hier wird verbringe ich
die ganze zeit damit dass ich freunde
finde freunde
wer braucht schon sowas hier vorne sind
noch zwei katzen auch okay dann kann ich
ja mit den beiden hier also zwei von
zwei ich hab immer noch zweifel habe ich
jetzt nicht viel passiert also die
beiden habe ich das sind ja ganz kleine
katzen und dahinten denen ihr habe ich
doch auch hier denn hier vorne genau sie
hier habe ich jetzt auch das heißt jetzt
habe ich drei von vier jetzt gehe ich
noch mal zu mir und jetzt muss ich ja
vier von vier haben genau
congratulations jeopardy vorne auf die
bälle
wir sind die alle bescheuert oder so in
der tat jetzt spielen wir alle katzen
mit irgendwelchen komischen bällen rum
und ich will eigentlich nur nach draußen
oder irgendwo in die russische stadt
oder irgendwie so aber jetzt steht hier
nur exit er indessen feuerwerk also froh
so ist ja so gekommen wie ich probiert
sondern wenn ich hier auf exit gehe auf
das tutorial dann endlich vorbei ist das
heißt wir sehen wieder den tollen kaktus
dort eingeblendet ja meine damen und
herren ich kann endlich auf play klicken
auf silber und wir können unsere eigene
katze machen wenn ihr wollt dass ich mir
meine eigene katze mache dann lasst mann
leiter und schreibt mir in die
kommentare haustier warum haustier ich
würde sagen wir kriegen jetzt trotzdem
erstmal auf silber haben jetzt ja auch
endlich verschiedene eine verschiedene
orte beziehungsweise maps wir haben geht
die perle days gameplay im team im team
ihn tommy haus und silbers neighborhood
ich würde sagen wir klickt man auf
silber holte es soll nicht nacht sein
sondern eine 4
die manager können wir kann man sagen 15
minuten hier sind war meine damen und
herren
und ich denke dass jede website eigenes
level in etwa ist also wir müssen dann
immer eigen andere katzen finden zum
beispiel die hier vorne
hallo da haben wir schon direkt die
erste ist hier scheint irgend ein
schlafzimmer zu sein macht die kleine
folgte jetzt oder was es wäre echt süß
kommt kommt hinterher ja natürlich ich
hey hier unten ist der keller genau da
können wir auch mal hingehen
der eingang her seine frau die geht
tatsächlich unglaublich ich weiß nicht
was mit dieser frau hier los ist
ich glaube sie versucht irgendwie nach
draußen zu gehen ich wir können ja mal
so ein bisschen bescheuert hier sehen
wir das spiegelbild von gilbert dahin
ist auch noch eine katze derzeit wir
können auch mal gucken für die hier
irgendwie bekommen genau damit schon
zwei von sechs hier sind fisch dem
müssen wir uns holen weil durch die
fische da dies auch irgendwie überall
vorhanden wie wird sagen das kommt läuft
jetzt noch ein bisschen weiter die
beiden hier kommen natürlich mit wir
haben zwei von 16 freunde hier ist ein
fisch auf einem auto drauf das heißt wir
gehen jetzt einfach mal auch die grafik
ist eigentlich echt geil
für so ein komisches spiel hier hinten
haben wir noch einen fisch dann holen
wir uns den mal noch hier hinten habe
ich auch noch irgendwo ein fisch gesehen
genau hier vorne liegt noch einer wir
haben noch eine katze dem ich jetzt
gerade mal akquiriert hier in unserer
ihr seid meine untertanen okay habt ihr
das versteht direkt das licht jagen ihr
seid meine untertanen die kleinen katzen
ich habe euch akquiriert hier für meine
bande und wenn ihr mich hier nicht durch
lasst dann setze ich mich jetzt erst mal
hin
ja und ich um jetzt den fisch und ihr
bleibt da alle sitzen ist klar
irgendwie muss ich meine autorität hin
noch ein bisschen mehr steigern den
fische vorne und uns auch noch mal eben
schnell da haben wir den tisch hier die
map ist sogar relativ groß diesmal darum
haben wir auch noch einen fisch wir
können mal schauen wo wir hier noch über
lang laufen können das sieht alles sehr
sehr geil aus muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen also die grafik
und nein und nein freunde der komischen
innenstadt schon wieder am start herr
wtf was ist denn los mit ihr sind auch
noch ein paar mehr katzen die kann ich
auch einfach mal an mia und das heißt
sie haben schon scott mit sieben katzen
lasst doch mal ein leichter freunde das
ist er mit ihr los alter sieht so aus
als hätte sie gerade übelsten stress mit
ihrem freund gehabt oder irgendwie sowas
sowie dahin läuft und wir jetzt eben
gegen ihn boxen oder so also the church
ich sehe gerade dass die oberteile hier
schon bei 35 minuten ist er mich wollte
das video an ich gar nicht so lange
halten aber es hat wirklich eigentlich
relativ viel zu bieten also ich mache
mir mal voll viele maps noch offen wenn
ihr also wollte dass ich dieses spiel
eventuell noch mal ein paar tage auf
einem kanal spieler und wir uns dann
vielleicht eine katze machen und sodann
last auf jeden fall mal leichter und
jetzt meine damen und herren kommt das
braucht man eigentlich in jedem video
auf das war auto jetzt das wasser ziehen
das was jetzt hier vom video hier können
jetzt hier meinen kanal abonnieren oder
hier unten mal einen job aus checken
jetzt findet ihr zwei andere videos und
wenn ihr schon abonnenten zeit könnt ihr
auch die glocke klicken dann willkommen
die winden berichtigungen
[Musik]